hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar working
with antigen-specific t-cells
i am michelle ashton of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
and brought to you by miltoni biotech we
encourage you to participate today
by submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
lauren fula
global product manager for antigen and
virus specific t
cells at miltoni biotech laurens you may
now begin your presentation
yeah hi and welcome everybody also from
my site
on this webinar on working with
antigen-specific t-cells
so in this webinar i will quickly
introduce to you our
complete workflow so from sample
preparation
to cell analysis to really work with the
cells in a very efficient
way so and actually in regard to the
experimental workflow
we at milton biotech strongly believe
that the future of t-cell analysis
has to be more standardized to really be
able to generate more robust and also
reliable results
so enjoy
so here you can see our agenda so i will
start with a short introduction and some
background on antigen-specific t
cells then i will introduce our product
and solutions to work with these cells
and then i will
finish with some workflow examples
so let's start with the introduction and
some background
so just a brief company presentation so
milton biotech was actually founded in
1989 by stefan milton himself
and is until now still the largest owner
managed company in germany
with more than three and a half thousand
employees worldwide
and what i think is really striking
of our employees are still working in
global research and development
and we have two main sites in germany
headquarters in berger's club
and also gmp manufacturing facility in
tesla road near berlin
and we have subsidiaries in 28 countries
and we also distribute our products to
additional 73 countries
so of course
sorry so of course all t cells are
basically antigen
we talk about t cells that were
activated before the analysis
by a specific antigen for example a
defined antigenic peptide
and this is really opposed to a
polyclonal activation via for example
cd3 or c28
so by this only t sets of a given
specificity are activated which means
that the initial frequency of these
cells is of course very rare
and of course antigen-specific t cells
and also virus-specific t cells play
key roles in the immune response against
viral bacterial infections but also
in
yeah so as i just said i'm sorry that
the slides were just stuck so they are
very
as for example infectious diseases tumor
immunology
but also more recently very important in
the development of these
new candidate vaccines against ask of
two pharmacological screening
immunomonitoring autoimmunity but also
allergology so how can we
analyze these
so how can we analyze the
antigen-specific t cells in a bit more
detail
so there in general there are two
methods that can be classified
classified into
um two categories so first there's the
direct analysis of t-cell specificity
for example via mhc
peptide multimeters and these
multimeters really provide the highest
specificity to identify the rare
virus-specific tumor-specific or other
antigen-specific t-cells
these peptide multimeters are really
working very well for cd8 positive t
cells but are limited for cd4 positive t
cells they also do not provide any
information on the functional capacity
of the subset
and they're also limited to a certain
range of defined peptides and also mhc
mod
in contrast there are the indirect
analysis methods which analyze more the
effector functions of t cells
for example via the secretion of
cytokines or also the upper regulation
of certain surface markers
so this this is this really represents
an indirect identification of virus
reactive t
cells after an antigen specific
stimulation
and these indirect methods that work
very well for all t-cell subsets also
including regulatory t
cells they provide t-cells subset
specific information
and they're also completely independent
of the antigen and donor
and most importantly these indirect
analysis methods can all be analyzed
using flow cytometry
so what could be analyzed
when used when analyzing
antigen-specific t-cells using flow
cytometry
so for example there is cd69 which
represents an early pan-t-cell
activation marker
that is expressed in almost all
activated t-cells
then we have cd25 which is also known as
the interleukin-2 receptor alpha subunit
which represents a more late activation
markers expressed
at 24 to 48 hours after activation
on almost all activated t cells
including activated regulatory t cells
then we have cd154 also known as cd40
ligament
which is really an idle activation
marker to analyze conventional c4
positive t
cells after about four to twelve hours
of stimulation
which is a very suitable activation
marker for c8 positive conventional t
cells but it's all that cd137
is also expressed on array on regulatory
t-cells but here with different kinetic
after 46 hours of stimulation and
finally of course we can also analyze
various cytokines
which can often activated t-cells
either measured in supernatant or also
on a single cell level
via for example intercellular cytokine
staining or ics
or using our cytokine secretion assays
and of course if you screw in the
literatures you
listed literature you might find
additional markers that could be
analyzed such as for example cd95
kki67 klrg1 and others
so as briefly mentioned before these
antigen-specific t-cells
have a really low cell frequency which
really represents one of the biggest
challenge
for a reliable analysis so let's just
have a look at the the
other key challenges and how we can
overcome them
so of course with low cell frequencies
it is all the more important to really
prepare the starting material in optimal
way
to really prevent losing the cells in
the first place
so to ensure high cell numbers the cells
can also be pre-enriched magnetically
or via flow sorting for example
another common problem with
antigen-specific t-cells is often the
insufficient simulation
and here only by using powerful reagents
and also really optimize
protocols the cells can be efficiently
stimulated
and then furthermore a reliable analysis
is often
let's say hampered by a high background
staining
just basically because these cells are
so rare
and here reagents for specific labeling
and sensitive detection methods
are really important of course and
finally there's often a rather slow
translation of these early findings into
the clinic
and here milton biotech actually has a
large portfolio for
let's say translational research that
could really help to
to speed up your your research
so to to really efficiently isolate
stimulate stain and analyze
antigen-specific t-cells
different technologies over an entire
workflow to ensure
successful analysis
and of course what we think is that the
right product combination here
so at milton biotech we're actually
offering complete workflow for the
analysis of antigen-specific t-cells
the workflow always starts with sample
preparation so here you would start from
pbmc
t-cells from tissues following the
isolation that
the t cells would need to be stimulated
either polyclonally or antigen-specific
using for example our peptivator peptide
tools
and then following stimulation the cells
are analyzed best with the more
standardized flow analysis panels
using for example our re-affinity
recombinant antibodies
and our max quant analyzers for flow
cytometry
however you could also think about
optionally isolating t
cells after preparing your sample which
will increase
tissue which will increase sensitivity
during analysis
and also save some time
so in addition following cell
stimulation you could also
magnetically pre-enrich your
antigen-specific t
cells using our microbead kits and here
i would
really like to to enrich billable
antidirective t
cells and then last but not least you
could either
directly after magnetic pre-enrichment
also sort your cells
using flow cytometer um or
also after amino phenotyping sort of
cleansing and here we have the max
quantity cell sorter
which really enables a sterile and also
aerosol-free cell sorting of these
rare antigen-specific t-cells
okay go ahead
okay very good so here you can just a
schematic overview of our products
that we offer for the analysis of
antigen-specific t-cells
and as you can see we actually offer
products for the whole workflow so from
sample preparation to cell culture
cell stimulation patient as well as cell
analysis
and if you want you can also have a look
at the respective application websites
you find here on the top
and you can just click on them right now
and you can also watch our other
webinars to check
for other t-cell subtypes
now let's continue with our products and
solutions
so for sample preparation we could start
for example with pbmcs
and for the isolation of pbmcs
we offer the max prep pvmc isolation kit
and this max prep pvc isolation kit
really provides a very fast and
untouched isolation of pvmcs in about 25
minutes
and you really do not need to lyse your
red blood cells or perform any density
gradient centrifugation
kit is also optimized for
millimeters and the cells are have a
very high purity
you will recover all of your cells and
they are also all viable
and on the graph here on the right side
you can see that the recovery
various immune subtypes found within
pvmcs
is at least as good if not even a bit
better compared to to conventional
density gradient centrifugation using
fico for example
but the more the kit really
eliminates any user dependent
inconsistencies and performs very
reliable with every preparation
so it is also idle um for for performing
any downstream analysis as the cells
are really viable so you could easily
analyze the cells using for example
single cell rna sequencing
or any other downstream essays and
furthermore
um the kids are also semi-automatable
using the multi-max cell 24 separator
plus which you can see here on the top
um to really allow you to analyze um
pbmcs from large cohort of
of samples however if you are interested
in isolating pvmcs for larger scales in
a more
automatable fashion we have also
recently released the so-called whole
blood tbmc
kit for human pbmcs
adopt so again so for
for some cases you might need to isolate
t cells
from tissues and here we have the
so-called gentlemax tissue dissociator
and also various kits so with the
gentlemax you can really
gently produce viable single cell
suspensions and also conserve epitopes
for analysis
it also works in very reproducible
fashion because it has a lot of
predefined programs for more
standardized tissue dissociation
and also with the gentlemax
octodissociator
you are able to work very fast so you
can process up to eight samples in
parallel
and it also includes a heater module
which allows you to perfectly
tune the temperature during tissue
dissociation
and finally with this this sterile
enclosed tubes you and your sample are
completely safe
during the dissociation process and as a
perfect addition
our tissue dissociation kits which kind
of combine
an enzymatic treatment with the with the
idle
program from the gentlemax you can
easily isolate t
cells from tissues such as spleen tumor
lung but also more complex tissues like
skin brain
and also lamina propria for example
so by the combination of this gentlemax
tissue dissociator
and the tissue distortion kits we can
guarantee you
a really high yield and viability
especially for these very rare
antigen-specific t cells so for
for cell stimulation we offer the
so-called peptidor peptide foods so
let's have a closer look at them
so peptide or peptide pools are really
the most efficient way to stimulate
antigen specific t cells
the peptivator peptide pools really
efficiently stimulate
both so cd4 and cd8 positive t cells and
we actually cover an extensive portfolio
of virus tumor fungi microbiota and also
alter antigens
the peptide pools always consist of 50
mere peptides with 11 amino acid
overhangs
which actually in most cases also covers
the complete sequence of the respective
antigen
and they are available in research
premium and even also
a max gmp grade which then will allow a
rapid translation of the early findings
into the clinic
and they're also available in high
throughput version
in a 96 well format so we think that
they're really the idle stimulation
reagents for both antigen and also
virus-specific t-cells
so as you can see here our peptidor
peptide pools really cover the most
important antigens ranging from various
viruses such as cmv
an epstein-barr virus but also more
recently peptivators for disaster f2
virus
however we also have two more antigens
such as dp100 and also melano-a
and the wilms tumor protein one but also
autoantigens like for example
mock and and insulin and in the plot
here on the right side you can see how
efficiently the perturbators actually
stimulate both cd4 positive t
cells shown on the left axis and cd8
positive t
cells shown on the right axis and here
we assess the expression of gamma
interferon
after stimulation with the respective
activator
into donors and furthermore as i've
already mentioned we also provide the
pathways for high throughput
applications
and with them you can really combine
multiple antigens in different stripes
on on just one single sa plate
which will really give you some some
more flexibility in analyzing the cells
and in addition this i think the setup
is really nice because you can stimulate
culture stain and analyze yourself
directly on the same plate
and this will of course save you some
time some
pipetting steps and also the aliquoting
and in consequence this then means that
your whole experimental setup
is less prone to to errors
so of course every stimulation
experiment let's say
also requires very reliable positive
control
and here our cytostem reagent can really
help you to further standardize your t
cell assays
so cytostem has been specifically
developed for rapid and efficient
stimulation of human effector and memory
and t
cells cytostem is an antibody based
reagent that actually crosslinks the t
cell receptor two mhc molecules
found on on antigen presenting cells it
is a non-toxic
alternative to the super antigen and
upon stimulation um cd4
and cd8 positive t cells will start to
secrete
effector cytokines such as gamma
interferon tnf alpha and interleukin-2
and also upregulate certain activation
markers like for example c1 or 37
and cd154 so again i think this is
really a
perfect positive control for stimulating
antigen and virus specific t
cells so let's have a quick look on our
tools that we offer for the t-cell
isolation
and also for magnetic pre-enrichment
following
stimulation so of course flow cytometry
is still
the main tool for the analysis of rare
t-cells
however even established methods like
closed cytometry have also certain
limiters
specific t-cells can be extremely rare
depending on the on the
condition and um these limits were
already illustrated years years
ago in a very nice publication by baka
and colleagues
where the authors analyzed
the sensitivity of flaw cytometry and
then state
that a floss atrocity is always limited
by the number of events that can be
recorded
as well as sustaining background which
is typically between 0.01 and 0.1
percent
so in consequence this really restricts
the analysis of rare cell populations
especially with
um lower frequencies so with modern flow
cytometers you will
normally be able to detect at least some
cells but there might be certain
conditions
where hardly any specific cell can be
detected
and here you can use our max microbial
so forward to to over
working with rare cells we provide the
reaffinity recombinant antibodies which
really have a very high specificity
and also superior a lot to lot
consistency and coupled with our biodyes
you can really ensure a bright staining
and also a low spillover of your
multi-parameter analysis
but we'll take a close
the antibodies
later on art cells
so for enrichment technology
makes the marks technology actually so
special
actually we just simply call it the
select the best approach so minimal
labeling
with no effects on cell function and a
full downstream compatibility
so but what are some of the key
advantages of this column based
technology
well actually the steel spheres within a
column amplify the magnetic field by
about ten thousand fold
so this amplification in turn then
allows for a really minimal labeling
and also the use of this nano size beads
which have a size of about 50 nanometers
and in consequence this also means that
there's less epitopes are covered on the
on the cellular surface
and also less stress is applied to the
cells
really enable a very gentle enrichment
as
the steel spheres have a very cell
friendly hydrophilic hydrophilic coating
and there's also a large space between
these two spheres
so the cells will just pass very
smoothly actually through the column
without suffering from any negative
effects
so in in summary the max technology is
really gentle to yourselves it will not
cause
any unspecific cell activation um it
ensures minimal labeling without
building any beat aggregates and you can
also see that here on the pictures on
the right side
which show microscopic pictures of t
cells that were enriched with our cd3
microbeads
or with microbeads from a competitor and
as you can see here on this over
labeling which is required for column
three enrichment
really results in these these speed
aggregates that can
already be seen in the cell culture and
also a massive over labeling
of beads on the cellular surface in
contrast using the max technology
you can see that there are no beat
aggregates forming in the cell culture
and there's also only minimal labeling
on the cell surface
so finally the max technology does not
really cause any cell iterations
or change the cell characteristics and
this is also why
our microbeads are heavily used in
clinical research
and several clinical trials for example
for cell manufacturing
and more than 55 000 patients have been
already
treated approved by the by the fda
so the max technology comes in four
different approaches to really
reflect your your different starting
materials so first we have the
microbeads and the microwave kits
which are made for the positive t-cell
separation from for example pvmcs
but also various other for example
tissues
or label-free cell separation and then
second we also have these so-called
isolation kits
that are made for an untouched isolation
of t-cells
because pvmc is all more defined
by
in your in your suspension so both
approaches
for both approaches we actually cover um
kids for the isolation of basic t
cells but also almost any t cell
subtypes from different
out red but also non-human primates
however if you want to skip for example
density gradient centrifugation
to isolate your pbmcs you can also use
our so-called straight from microbead
kits
so these straight from microbeads kits
are also for the positive isolation
of human cd3 c4 and c8 positive t cells
and stratform is a very reliable way way
to get your t
cells super fast and is also a complete
and last but not least we also have the
so-called max express isolation kit
which will also isolate your t-cells in
an untouched fashion
directly from whole blood however with
the max express
it approach
the column free methods so in contrast
to the other technologies
express is not automatable but still it
is very fast
and and also absolutely uncomplicated to
use
and actually indeed results after
pre-enrichment using for example our
cd154 or c137 micro bit kits
are really good so while cd 154 is up
regulated on activated cd4 positive t
cells cd 137 is up regulated on
activated c
stimulated pbmcs with the cmv peptivator
or left them untreated as a control
and then in both conditions the t cells
were enriched using the respective
microbeads kits
and then the cells were analyzed using
flow cytometry
and as you can see hardly any cell
expressing cd164 or c1 and 37
can be found in the in the unsimulated
sample however following stimulation
these
specific t cells that heavily up
regulated cd1 and 54 and cd137
could be easily enriched and then these
these isolated cells could then be
easily
be used in any downstream application
like for example
tcr sequencing and if you want you can
have a look at our nice tech paper
shown here at the top which illustrates
the technology in
more detail
and furthermore to quickly point out a
technology that is absolutely unique and
these are the
cytokine secretion assays so in contrast
to intracellular staining approaches the
cytokine secretion as they really allow
a viable enrichment of cytokines
repeating t cells both from mouse
and human samples and the principle is
actually rather simple so first
the secreted cytokines are immobilized
on the cellular surface by the so-called
catch reagent
which basically labels the cell itself
own cytokine
and then in the second step immobilized
cytokines
are then labeled with a fluorophore
conjugated antibody called the detection
reagent and by this living cells can be
detected without intracellular staining
and then optionally in a third step the
fluorophore can be labeled
can also be used for enrichment
so with the help of antifluorophome
antiflora for magnetic beads
you can then enrich these these positive
cells
so consequently our our cytokine
secretion essays
actually come in two versions so we have
these so-called detection kits
for flow analysis only while for the
enrichment and analysis of viable
cytokinesic reading cells we have
so called enrichment and detection kits
so here you can see an overview of our
solutions
and markers that can be used for the
enrichment of antigen
activated cells so for example we have
to see 154 microbials that can be used
for the detection and enrichment of the
whole
analyze the cells after hours of
stimulation
in contrast you have this cd1 or 37
microbead kits where you can analyze the
whole
scda responses for cd 137 expression on
cd8 for the
t cells we recommend to stimulate your
cells for at least 16 hours
and finally our cytokine secretion as
of really viable cytokine secreting
cells
so now let's have a look at our tools
for cell analysis
and here we have the so-called
reaffinity recombinant antibodies and
our biodyes
so these three affinity antibodies have
been really designed with flow cytometry
in mind
they are very recombinantly and first
highest purity and also highest law to
lock consistency
see they all have the same universal
idd1 isotype which really make
will make your experimental design much
more simple
rotate the dfc region
which will prevent the antibody to bind
to fc receptors
and therefore also reduce background
staining and then coupled with our
biodyes which have a very high stain
index and also low
over there are actually the perfect
reagents for the analysis of rest
these cells we actually cover all the
markers
um that you want to analyze and we are
also always happy to help you
with the design of your flow panel
so apart from the reaffinity recombinant
antibodies
we also have many all-in-one solutions
in the form of of kits which will help
you to analyze
antigen virus specific t cells example
more recently we added the so-called
lasck of two t-cell analysis kits
which allow you to stimulate and analyze
the ask of directive t cells
in pbmc or whole blood samples so the
kids already contain a zask of two
included fully optimized flow panel of
eight to nine
affinity antibodies depending on the
version of the kit we included the live
dead die the viability phone at 552
we worked on a very optimized intro and
extracellular scanning
protocol we included all the required
buffers and reagents such as for example
in a so you can directly start with your
experiment and the kids have a very high
capacity of up to 100 tests
or up to 10 to the power of eight cells
it's also good to know that the kids
really work best
processor and both kits so the kit for
pbmc as well as
whole blood samples are also available
without a captivator peptide
and therefore could be used for the
analysis of other specific
specificities for example and as you can
see in the plot here on the right
specifically activated last
cd4 ncd8 positive t so analyzed here by
the expression of the
skin of urine can be detected in just
one sram
just one sample through a combined
analysis of various activation markers
like for example c1 and 54 interferon or
tnf alpha
so apart from the affinity antibody and
his ask of two pieces
we also have other very convenient and
also ready to use flow kits
for example we have the rapid cytokine
inspector which ensures
a rapid multi-parameter analysis of
activated cd4 and cd8 positive t
cells and it basically does that by one
step detection of surface markers
and intracellular cytokines then we also
have the
so-called maxplex cytokine kits for both
human and mouth
samples and here using a multiplex
analysis
the kids can actually measure the
concentrations of up to 12 or 10
different cytokines
in cell culture supernatants and the
technology is based on our maxflex
capture beats which will basically work
on any standard flow cytometer
and then finally we also have the
so-called eight-color immuno phenotyping
kit
which enables an optimized flow-based
evaluation of various lucased subsets
such as for example monocytes
neutrophils eosinophils t and b cells as
well as nk cells
and our flow portfolio is rounded off
with our flow analysis and forting
instruments
of the the so-called max quan series so
first we have the max point analyzer
which is a really powerful benchtop flow
cytometer
with up to 16 optical parameters
and really the clue here is that it
allows for fully automated acquisition
using a
robotic sample collector and
the so called express mode so these
express modes you can imagine as some
kind of software modules that are
pre-installed on your mac squad
and the low and automated analysis of
your
flow analysis results and furthermore
um the instrument is really small and
you can easily
place it basically under every um flow
hood
and second we also have the max quant
tidal cell sorter
which opposed to classical droplet
sorters
allows for a more gentle cell sorting
approach
and higher viability even for the rare
and sensitive cells
and it therefore it uses a microchip
sorting technology
to to um sort yourselves in a mechanical
way
so furthermore does this closed and
steric cartridge system
really make the title the idle
instrument for basically any gmp
environment
and here i would like to to have a short
look especially on on the max quantile
cell sorter
so with the with the really unique
capabilities like this gentle
cell sorting and the clothes and
stereocartridge system
um the title is really good for the
isolation of
rare t-cells so for example for
theirization of car t
cells regulatory t cells but also car
t-rex
antigen-specific t-cells but also of
course virus-specific t
cells so let me just just briefly point
out that the title is already being part
of several clinical trials actually
involving the analysis of tumor specific
cells
as can be seen here on the list on the
right side
okay let's now let's now come to some
application
workflow examples and the last part for
today
so i would like to start with the rapid
cytokine inspector
which will help you to simultaneously
stain diesel activation markers such as
cd1 and 54
as well as various effectors cytok
actually either to detect cells with
with a with a relatively low frequency
of let's say 0.1 to 0.01 percentage of
the total t
cell so here on the right side you can
see a typical application workflow so
first you would need to isolate your
pbmcs
then you stimulate the cells either
antigen-specific
specifically with with for example our
peptidated peptide pools
or polyclonally with for example
anti-cd3c28
then you would stain your surface
markers for about 10 minutes
fix the cells for 20 minutes and then
perform a permeabilization
and intracellular staining for about 20
minutes so this whole protocol of the
rapid cytokine inspector takes only 40
minutes
before you can go ahead and start
analyzing your cells using
flow cytometry and of course the rapid
cytokines vector is also
compatible with our max express modes
for
format for the max quant analyzer so
the rapid cytokines vector could be for
example used for
fast and automated assessment of antigen
reactive cd4 and cd8 positive t
cells from pvmc samples it could also be
used for the immune monitoring of
antigen-specific t
cells but also for example to test the
eligibility
of a lookup for resist products by for
example assessing the presence
of for example virus-specific t-cells
so actually in this um example here you
can see
how the rapid cytokine inspector
compares to standard protocols for
intracellular cytokine staining
so here pbmcs were stimulated with the
cmv peptivators pp65
and ie1 were left untreated as a control
and then the frequencies of cmv
specifics d4 and c8 positive t
cells were analyzed and as you can see
the frequencies are completely
comparable between two approaches
with the striking difference that the
rapid cytokine inspector protocol
only takes about 45 minutes to complete
so in the second example human pbmcs
were again incubated with the cmv
pp65 captivator for six hours
and then after two hours we added
refilling a
and then we analyzed the cell however
here we
use the rapid cytokines vector to
analyze the expression of gamma
interferon
and interleukin-2 on these
antigen-activated cd8-positive t-souls
and as you can see here we successfully
detected both interferon gamma-positive
single single-positive cells as well as
interferon gamma
and interleukin-2 double positive cells
so next i would like to quickly
introduce the so-called rapid auto
rapid auto protocol which stands for
rapid antigen reactive t cell enrichment
and rapid art is actually what i think
the perfect solution for the analysis of
rare antigen-specific t-cells
as it combines cell stimulation surface
marker staining intracellular cytokine
staining
and an enrichment step based on t-cell
activation markers such as for example
c1 or 54
or c1 or 37. however what i think is
really
really cool about rapid archer is that
permeabilization and intracellular
cytokine staining can be performed
directly on the column
and it's actually perfect for very low
target cell frequencies of 0.01
to actually 0.001 percentage of the
total dc population
so and rapid art it can be for example
used for the identification of
rare virus reactive t cells such such as
for example dark of two reactive t
cells but also for the detection of rare
tumor-specific t
cells for example wims tumor protein one
specific t
cells it can also be used for for
detailed analysis
of the complete rare cd4 positive and
cd8 positive these are referencer
and also be used for cytokine profiling
for example of
fixed fungi or tumor-specific t-cells
so let's have a quick look at a
virus-specific example where the rapid
art protocol was applied
so here pmc is from a covert 19 survivor
and a healthy donor were stimulated with
a mix of vascops to peptivators
a mix of influenza peptide is a positive
control or also left untreated
and as you can see in the middle panel
the rare zarskofter active t
cells were successfully enriched using
cd1 and 54
and could then be easily visualized in
in in flow cytometry analysis
and the data was actually provided by
the courtesy of alexander sheffold and
also petra bacha
from the university clinic schlesik
holstein in
kiev germany and if you want to find out
more about the rapidata protocol
please have a look at their publication
here and also in this in the second
publication here on the on the lower
right
the rapid art protocol was used for the
enrichment of the ask of two reactive
cd8 positive t cells
so in this last example for today i
would like to quickly show you how you
could use our mux technology to enrich
antigen-specific t-cells
via peptide msc multimeters so again we
can combine cell
separation and flow staining directly in
one step
and as you can see in a workflow here on
the right side we would first need to
stain the cells using a highly specific
mhd peptide multimeter that is coupled
to fluorophore such as for example apc
or pe and then in the second step we
label cells with antifluor for
microbeads
and this way we'll then specifically
enrich only those cells that express
the distinctive receptor and then
following illusion
we can directly analyze the enriched
cells using um flow cytometry
so this method is really um idle for an
in and for an efficient in-depth ex vivo
analysis of this rare antigen-specific
t-cells furthermore you could also
use this approach to for the enrichment
and multi-parameter analysis
of ultra-rare anti-specific cd4 and c8
positive seasons
for example to analyze naive
tumor-specific t-cells
it will ensure flexible enrichment via
this entry flow microbeads so this way
the approach is also adaptable to mhc2
multimeters and c4 positive t
cells and we can combine mhc multimeter
staining also with interest on the
cytokine staining
and here we have definitely developed an
optimized protocol
that you can that you can click on here
so in this last example we used
in a publication from from smead and
colleagues published in immunology in
2015
naive williams tumor protein one
specific cd8 positive t cells
were analyzed in healthy donors so this
wilms tumor protein one is a
transcription factor that is expressed
at high levels
in um several hematological but also
some solid tumors
it is highly oncogenic and actually
ranked as one of the
the top tumor associated antigens
for for cancer immunotherapy however
the authors here found that relatively
little is noun about the presence and
also functional
relevance of these wt1 specific t cells
and healthy donors
so in this study naive pvmcs were first
stained with wt1 tetramers coupled to
apc and pe
and then antipe microbeads were used to
specifically enrich
wt1 specific cd8 positive t cells before
the analysis using flow cytometry
so for the analysis that and actually
employed employed two internal control
mechanisms
to control for non-specific background
staining
so as already said they performed this
dual labeling with tetramers conjugated
to pe
and fpc and then analyzed only the
double positive events
and second they also analyzed the
tetramer staining on c4 positive t cells
as an internal reference standard
but as you can see this this ultra rare
wt1 specific cd8 positive t
cells could be successfully enriched
using the anti-pe microbeads
and then further analysis actually
revealed that the cells displayed
a naive city 45 air a positive ccr7
positive phenol
phenotype so they also actually conclude
that the the majority of wt1 specific
cd8 positive t
cells detected in healthy donors
originate from a naive desert pool
and if you want to have more details you
can also have a look at their
publication
here in the lower right corner
so this was our our last example for
today and again i'm really sorry that
i lost the connection between but let me
just briefly sum up the the main things
of today
so really the key for for the analysis
of rare t cells is to prevent
cell loss from early on to pre-enrich
your cells to use the most
efficient tools for stimulation and also
make sure that they have a very low
background staining
and we at milton biotech actually offer
a complete workflow for the analysis of
antigen-specific t
cells which includes an optimal pbmc
isolation with our pvmc isolation kits
um tools for the efficient sample
preparation with the gentlemax tissue
dissociator
and also our tissue dissociation kits
potential stimulation with the
captivator peptide pools
efficient free enrichment of
antigen-specific t-cells using cd137
c154 microbead kits
cytokine secretion assays as well as
anti-flour for microbeads
microbead kits you need a low background
staining and you can achieve that with
our
affinity recombinant antibodies we offer
many all-in-one
flow analysis kits both for surface
marker staining as well as cytokine
analysis such as for example a rapid
cytokine inspector as well as the
maxplex
kits and using the mux point analyzer
and the tidal cell sorter you can ensure
an automated flow analysis
and a very gentle cell sorting
so just please recognize the
display disclaimer and with this i come
to an end
and i would really like to thank you
very much for your attention and for
for staying on and i'm happy to take any
of your questions either now or also
later
thank you lauren for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
all right let's go ahead and get started
okay so your first
question let's see is
do you also have peptivator peptide
pools for the new sars kobe 2 variants
of concern oh yeah that's a very good
question so actually in fact we just
released several peptide peptide pools
for all the new mutations that are
originally discovered for example in uk
south africa brazil
also most recently in india and for this
this mutation pools we actually always
offer
two um two pools uh one is the mutation
pool which covers the mutated sequence
and one is the respective y type control
pool so
really by performing separate simulation
with the mutation and the reference pool
you can then detect
and analyze this mutation specific these
are responses
all right great thank you okay your next
question
can the sars covi2 t-cell analysis
kits also be used for the analysis of
other antigen-specific
t-cells oh yeah that's also an
interesting question so as i've said in
my in my presentation
we've also just released a version of
the kit that does not
include a peptivator peptide pool so in
this in this kit version
you could just use your own stimulation
control to stimulate for example
tumor-specific t-cells
and then just use the included reagents
and the included flow panel
to analyze antigen-specific t-cells
okay great thank you and your next
question
could you please quickly explain how the
max prep pbnc isolation kit works
so the isolation of pvmcs using the kit
is actually performed with only one
um one labeling step and also in a two
two-step separation procedure so during
the first isolation
step erythrocytes are aggregated and
just sedimented
and then in the second step the pvmcs
are isolated
by the depletion of of non-pbmc so
neutrophils eosinophils platelets and
and residual
electrocytes so by this you will isolate
untouched dbmcs
hey is there a surface marker that could
be used for the enrichment of regulatory
t
cells oh that's an interesting question
so for the enrichment of regulatory t
cells we actually recommend to
also use cd 137 however here
um cd137 is expressed on activated cd8
positive t
cells as well so if you want to
specifically enrich regulatory t
cells you should only stimulate your
cells for about four to six hours
then cd137 is expressed on regulatory t
cells
while if you stimulate your cells for
for an extended period of time you will
also enrich cd8 positive t
cells
thank you lauren looks like we have time
for one last question here
um how many samples can be analyzed
using the sars kobe 2 t cell analysis
kit
so the kids are actually optimized to
perform 100 tests however for the
analysis of one donor we strongly
recommend
to always include a separate negative
and positive control
so in total this means you could analyze
up to 33 donors
and always have a positive and a
negative control
included
well thank you again lauren for your
time today and we would also like to
thank
labruz and our sponsor miltoni biotech
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
and before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
i know we ran out of time today so any
questions that were submitted that we
didn't answer today
or those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed
by our speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
and we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
all right well until next time thank you
and goodbye